哎大家好
今天我们来聊一个
我觉得超酷的主题
你知道吗
在股市里
当大家吓得要死
最恐慌的时候
搞不好
反而是赚大钱的最好时机
我们今天就来拆解这个策略
好你先想象一下
如果我是说如果
每一次的市场崩盘
其实都跟着一个固定的剧本在走
那会怎么样
嗯
这听起来好像有点天方夜谭
对不对
但你先别急
因为历史数据告诉我们
这背后可能真的有一套规则可循
这可不是在乱猜哦
我们今天要讲的是一种叫做灾难财的策略
听起好像很坏
但它其实是一种完全反直觉
而且有数据知识的获利方法
它的核心是抓住一个过去二十几年来
在台股一再上演
但很多人都没注意到的市场机制
所以啦
这个秘密到底是什么
其实一切的关键
都围绕着一个神奇的数字
你可以把它想象成
一个埋在市场里的绊脚索
一旦有人踩到
整个游戏规则
就会瞬间改变
就是这个数字
130%
记住它
这东西叫做融资维持率
当整个市场的杠杆
也就是大家借钱买股票的比例
跌破这条线的时候
嗯
一些可预测
而且非常强大的事情就要发生了
好 那这个融资维持率到底是啥我讲白话一点这就是台湾股市的一个硬性规定如果你借钱买股票结果股票大跌让你户头里的钱
低于你借款金额的130%
券商就会打电话给你
叫你补钱
你不补
不好意思
隔天电脑就会自动
强制把你的股票全部卖掉
重点是强制而且是电脑自动
这跟人性的恐慌一点关系都没有
所以你看
这个连锁效应是这样发生的
市场一跌
跌破13%
接着全市场的断头令
就开始一个一个爆出来
然后呢
券商的电脑就开始
无情的自动的抛售股票
等到这些被迫卖出股票的福尔
全部被清洗干净之后
卖压就突然消失了
市场上会瞬间变成一个真空状态
然后咻
一个超猛的V型反弹就出现了
这整个过程就叫做
强制去杠杆
光说不练没有用嘛对不对
我们直接来看历史证据
因为在过去这二十几年
这个剧本真的上演不止一次了
你看这张表
哇真的超明显的
不管是2000年的网络泡沫
2008年那个吓死人的金融海啸
还是2020年的COVID烹盘
你有没有发现一个惊人的共同点
每一次真的是每一次哦
只要市场整体的融资维持率
跌到130%这条危险线附近
市场在接下来的几个月
都出现了一次
非常非常强劲的反弹我们来讲一个最近也最扯的例子就是资料里提到的22025年,那时候因为关税风暴,市场大恐慌,融资维持率最低杀到118%,结果呢,大盘指数从24000点直接V转盆到32000点。
你想想看,在那个时候敢进场的人,光是大盘指数就赚了超过三成,是不是超夸张的啊?
好,历史证据看完了
那重点来了
我们到底要怎么做
别担心,这一套方法其实有很清楚的SOP
就三步,我们一步一步来看
整个策略的精髓其实就两个字
耐心
第一步,先看市场的温度计
也就是整体的融资维持率
当它接近140%的时候
你就要开始注意了
第二步,从那些已经被杀得很惨
融资维持率也低于130%的股票里面
去挑出你的观察名单
然后第三步
这也是最最重要的
不要第一天就冲进去
你要等讯号
这张图很重要哦
它告诉你新手跟老手的差别在哪
新手就是看到跌了就冲进去
那在台股叫什么
叫接吊下来的刀子
通常只会弄得自己满手是血
专业的讯号是什么
是你要等待市场出现一根带有长长下影线的K棒
或是隔天直接开出一根强力的红K棒
这代表什么
这代表那一大坡电脑的强制慢压
已经被更聪明更有钱的大户全部拾下来了这时候进场才是相对安全的时机OK 讲了这么多我们来做个总结
所以我们到底是在遍地恐慌中剪钻石
还是在接空中飞来的刀子呢
关键就在于你懂不懂这些数字背后的意义
我们直接看数字
这个数字真的有点吓人
根据长达26年的历史回测
这套策略的胜率高达85%以上
而且在进场后的6个月
平均报酬率是27.4%
说真的啊
在投资界
你说这不是圣杯
什么才是圣杯
不过有几个重点
你一定要记在心里
第一
这不是天天有的机会
大概两三年才会出现一次
第二
你是在逆风操作
所以进场的时机点
就是一切
第三
也是最重要的
千万不要在市场好好的
融资维持率
还在150%以上的时候
用这招
那不叫减钻石
那真的就只是在接刀子而已
最后
所有的数据都是公开的
真正的价值不在资讯
而在于你怎么去应用它
所以你看讲到最后
这一切根本就没有什么
秘密资讯可言
真正的问题其实是
当所有人都吓到跑路
夺门而出的时候
你有没有那个勇气
去执行你的计划
然后按下那个买进的按钮
这个问题就留给大家自己思考了